Speaker 1: today by talking about gay Republicans.
Gay Republicans at one point thought, hey,
you know what, they're going to accept us in the
Republican Party. Gay marriage is now legal. It's
kind of becoming a non-issue. And if we are for
low taxes, if we are for low regulation, if we
are about Christian values, whatever that means
at the time that they say it within the context
of the Republican Party, the Republican Party will
accept us because it's moved on to other things.
And unfortunately, punctuated with last week's
vote against marriage equality from 157 different
Republicans in the House of Representatives. It
is now abundantly clear that gay Republicans have
failed at being integrated into the Republican
Party. The Republican Party is seeing a sort
of resurgence of overt homophobia. Now, it's
important to understand that. Overt is the
key word. The homophobia never went away from the
Republican Party. There was this moment after gay
marriage was legalized and Donald Trump became the
Republican nominee, where Donald Trump would say
he's fine with gay people and gay marriage
and just kind of look the other way. It's
a non-issue. And quite frankly, on a personal
level, I think Trump doesn't care at all about
gay marriage. I think he's just it's not even an
issue he really cares about. But slowly but surely
and we're going to talk about this in the next
segment as the Christian element of the Republican
Party has become more overtly nationalistic.
And by that, I don't mean they happen to be
Christians and they are nationalists. I mean
they are Christian nationalists specifically,
as the trans issue has gotten good, has
made headway in reigniting some of these
visceral cultural issues, social issues for
Republicans. They've sort of been drawn back to
the base, fundamental homophobia. That was
a critical part of the Republican Party
for a long time. But acutely at the end of the
George W Bush era and during the Barack Obama era,
there has been there was a period of time on the
show where we would much more regularly cover
the overt homophobia, old school homophobia from
the Republican Party in the Bush era and in the
Obama era of the David Pakman show, we were often
talking about the outrageous homophobic tirades on
the floor of the House and on various talk radio
programs by right wing Republicans. It was a much
more common thing, and in the Trump era, there
was far less of it. Now, I'm not saying all of a
sudden the Republican Party was enlightened on gay
rights. That's not what I'm saying at all. What
I'm saying is they were less overtly homophobic
because they moved on to other things, including
the trans issue. It's important to mention. Well,
very interesting article now in the Texas Tribune,
we failed the gay Republicans who fought for
acceptance in the Texas Republican Party.
See little progress. Progress. Gay Republicans
who have fought for acceptance within the Texas
GOP over the past three decades told the Texas
Tribune Progress has been excruciatingly slow.
That's quite an understatement. Many of them
have left the party, even as the number of
Log Cabin Republicans in Texas continues to grow.
Log Cabin Republicans is a gay Republican group,
and the article sort of tells the story
of how there was this period of time,
I guess we would say, after the AIDS crisis, where
there was the idea that, listen, we're gay, but
we want low taxes and we want low regulation and
we're Christian family values, whatever. And the
Republican Party's a big tent, and they'll welcome
us probably as long as we have donor dollars. And
there may have been a brief period of time
where it seemed like that was a plausible thing,
but it has stopped. And fundamentally what this
comes down to is there is a group of male, mostly
wealthy white gay men who think will be accepted
as the good guys. As long as we more or less say
the right things, they might not love us, but
they'll look the other way about being gay and
will be part of the Trump GOP. They were never
really going to be welcomed into the George W
Bush GOP during the Obama era. It was this kind of
transitional phase, and then the Trump GOP might
welcome us, but it turns out that they don't.
And it's a very similar thing to Caitlyn Jenner.
Caitlyn Jenner. Great. Caitlyn Jenner, Republican
doesn't like woke whatever. She understands that
to mean, doesn't like liberals and all this stuff,
but then gets booed out of CPAC because of course,
she did. Of course she did. And it would sort of
be funny if it wasn't tragic on multiple levels.
I'll tell you what, some of those levels
are one level on which the continued
homophobia and transphobia of the Republican Party
is tragic is that it's 2022. And when you have
a duopoly in the United States, there's two
major parties. When one of those parties in 2022
remains openly transphobic and homophobic. You
see how retrograde and recalcitrant the country
is if you look at some other countries. Every
country has homophobia, don't get me wrong. But
there are countries, including some countries
in Europe, some countries in South America,
to a lesser degree, with multi-party systems where
you might have, you know, six major parties and
five are very much on the same page, like, listen,
of course, gay people can get married. Of course,
nobody should be able to get fired for their real
or perceived sexual orientation. And then you've
got like one homophobic party in the United
States. We have a duopoly and one of the two
parties is still basically overtly homophobic.
You have some Republicans who are like, listen,
it's a decided issue. It's not like they're going
to. Scheer Gay marriage. It's not like they're
going to cheer. Not being able to fire people
because you believe that they're gay, but they'll
say it's a decided issue. And we're moving on to
other things. But it is very retrograde. That's
one level on which it is tragic. The second level
on which it's tragic is the Republicans who are
gay, who are desperate to be accepted into this
party that just doesn't want them. And they'll
probably take their money in most cases under
not protest, but sort of like turning their nose,
you would say, but they're not going to like
it. And that's sad as well, because, listen,
there's nothing wrong with being gay and wanting
low taxes and thinking low taxes are the right
thing. That okay, you know, people have different
views about what the level of taxation should be.
But overall, the Republican Party is
this movement that's much more than
just low taxes. It's much more than just low
regulation. It is increasingly a fundamentalist
Christian nationalist worldview, reactionary
in ways that they don't even fully understand.
And you'll see some examples of that later in
the show when we look at the new Alex Jones
conspiracy theories that even his followers don't
get. But it's like it sort of sounds okay and it's
tragic on that level as well. But that's what it
is. And it seems at this point the movement for
the gay Republicans to be integrated into the
Republican Party not going particularly well.